Chadwick Boseman followed in the footsteps
of a whole host of elite superhero actors
by getting seriously ripped for his role as
T'Challa in Black Panther—but his Hollywood
fitness journey actually started well before
he joined the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Here's some insight into how Chadwick got
chiseled.
The path to Panther
T'Challa isn't Boseman's first physically
demanding role.
In 2013, he portrayed Jackie Robinson in the
biographical drama 42.
As well as capturing Robinson's off-field
contribution to the civil rights movement,
Boseman needed to appear authentically athletic
for scenes on the field.
To prepare, Boseman trained twice a day for
three and a half months, following the same
techniques as the pros.
In an interview with GQ, he referred to the
sessions as "madness" due to the strain such
activity places on the body.
Aside from swinging his hips and shuffling,
Boseman's appearance as the Godfather of Soul,
James Brown, must have been a breeze compared
to 42, right?
Wrong.
When portraying a musician as influential
as Brown, the pressure is on to not only sound
the same, but to move the same, as well.
Boseman had to do the splits while filming
Get On Up—not once, but 96 times.
The actor admitted that day's shooting was
harder than any activity he performed as Jackie
Robinson.
Secret training
Unlike some of his fellow MCU stars, Boseman
has remained tight-lipped when it comes to
divulging the secret of his regimen.
When asked by E! News prior to Civil War's
release, he refused to share any inside information
for those looking to emulate his results:
"A lot of strength and flexibility, but I'm
not going to say any more.
I can't say or reveal their training secrets."
Though Boseman hasn't disclosed the specifics
of his workout plan, all actors in the MCU
are notoriously put through their paces, and
he won't escape what Captain America himself,
Chris Evans, refers to as "absolutely brutal"
sessions.
"A couple of hours a day.
And it was, it was brutal.
The tricky part was eating."
"Did you have to eat lots?"
"Just eating everything all the time."
But the key to achieving Boseman's lean physique
likely lies more with classic bodybuilding
techniques, including circuit training, and
a less substantial diet that still adds power
to Black Panther's claws.
While Evans needed to pack on the pounds in
a short span of time, Boseman's goal of remaining
lean meant he could increase his body mass
at a slower rate.
This meant an extra emphasis on cardiovascular
and circuit training, to burn more calories.
For explosive movements, Boseman would focus
on plyometric training, which increases power
by working on "fast twitch" muscle fibers.
Combat work likely tops it all off, with training
in a variety of martial arts.
Losing muscle for Marshall
Sandwiched between performances as Black Panther,
Boseman played Thurgood Marshall in the 2017
bio-pic Marshall, replacing Civil War's airport
battles with clashes in the courtroom.
Understandably, Boseman would look out of
place as the future Supreme Court Justice
if he maintained the mass, so to fit tailored
trousers and well-fitted blazers, the actor
needed to strip away 25 pounds of hard-earned
muscle.
Between the wrap on Marshall and the beginning
of Black Panther's production in January 2017,
Boseman needed to recover lost muscle mass
to ensure his shoulders could carry the weight
of expectation for his return as T'Challa.
With the added spotlight and increased screen
time, Boseman's training regimen will presumably
have been even more intense than his Civil
War workout, but the principles will remain
the same—a gradual progression of lean mass.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!